a little bit about so also I'm not
affiliated with the write the docs
organization it's a fantastic
organization but I'm not affiliated with
them but auto-generate the docs didn't
really roll off the tongue so we're
stuck with this title but they do really
cool work and you should check them out
and I think Nathan he was saying he
knows the LA chapter lead for write the
doc so should hit him up so a little bit
about me I'm a senior data scientist on
the integrated analytics team at mean
agree mean degrees of reinsurance firm
and I gave the same explanation last
year it's your insurance company needs
insurance and we provide the insurance
for them so it's insurance for insurance
it's very very interesting but before I
started meeting agree I actually did a
graduate degree in math which means I
don't know how to write code has
everyone to see yes so I don't have
software engineering background or
anything but I did do this fellowship
which was the data science for social
good fellowship at the University of
Chicago which takes graduate students in
math physics and in kind of applied
discipline and teaches them data science
skills including even you know how you
should write Python code how should you
work in teams for social good projects
so in my time there I worked with the
City of Milwaukee to identify students
who are at risk of interacting with the
criminal justice system but you know
this was Obama administration but that
you know after that I left the
University of Chicago and I started
working at Munich Re and mean agree were
a relatively small team what we don't
we're not we don't have you know
hundreds of data engineers or data
scientists supporting us we do lots of
lots of our work is one-off client
analyses of their data looking for
insights mining their data and also
deploying products internally and
externally so when we were thinking
about what does good documentation look
like we didn't really need you know not
everyone on our team or even you know I
was not familiar with anything beyond
writing docstrings like
why would I ever need some further
documentation beyond this and so we
talked about integrating Sphinx and how
that could work for our specific use
case so this talk is very much for you
know novices who maybe never even heard
of Sphinx and I want to talk through
like how easy it is how we got around
that talk about like our use case why
you know the back end of Sphinx is very
different than just publishing a simple
readme or a markdown file and some best
practices and talk a little bit about
how we deploy our documentation for our
team running local servers because those
data we work with a sensitive and some
of our insights are sensitive so I think
everyone knows why good documentation is
important mostly for your own use you
know the person who suffers the most
when you write poor documentation is you
because you don't remember what that
function with 15 inputs does you know
first of all bad function of 15 inputs
but you know I've been there and then
working in a heavily regulated industry
like life insurance or health insurance
there's a lot of compliance factors with
any transforms you may be applying to
your data or any for example if I'm
using specific software or specific
piece of code to geocode against the
Census API I need to make sure that the
person using it next is using you know
the same versions and so the
documentation of your code there is very
important it helps these project
transitions you know you may be swamped
you're bored on this one project and
like oh well there's an intern maybe
they'd like to work on this project and
makes their life very easy if you have
good code and then for us specifically
like collaborating on small teams like
we're work on projects between with 2 to
3 people on staff one data scientist
maybe two data engineer or something
like that actually it's usually two data
scientists when there's never enough
data engineering support to go around I
don't know if anyone else can relate but
the other you know reason you need good
documentation is working on very huge
teams with the internet right open
source project so I'm sure you've all
seen some of the documentation around
like bouquet and
Kaler and it looks so so beautiful and
bouquet specifically they their
documentation is it's gorgeous and they
run their own like documentation server
and they've got all this customizations
on Sphinx but the backend of that is the
same that streamlet is using and
streamlet the I think the founder of the
startup presented yesterday I was in
this tutorial and I went through and I
love looking documentation so I was like
oh wow he's just using Sphinx just like
everybody else but it makes it all your
documentation look really great and so
what is Sphinx if you've never heard of
it it's a document generator and it
takes plain text files and turns them
into beautiful and shiny HTML PDFs and
if you've ever been on read the docs
read the docs all those different
packages the documentation is hosted in
Sphinx and it Auto generates these
templated docs and takes care of all all
of that and the great benefit of Sphinx
is that your documentation is then part
of your source repository so just how
you version your code you can then
version documentation because it sits in
your github and just how you setup
continuous integration and deployment
pipelines for your products or tools you
can do the same on your documentation so
for for for voce they won't even accept
a pull request if it doesn't have some
associated documentation changes with it
so that's uh that's an example there so
getting started with Sphinx is really
really easy anyone can do it it's got
these you know five commands that you
run and it will and this Fink's
QuickStart what it does I don't know if
you guys have ever used cookie cutter
but again that templates and it'll ask
you set a few questions and then it will
generate a directory structure that will
be leveraged to build out your
documentation so so I made project
called PI data I've got my setup pot pie
in there and then within the docs it set
up these few files so in this I guess
the things will go through them in in
order but the make file is what is used
to
your documentation so the few commands
that you know you need off the top of
your head make clean clean out all the
old documentation generated make HTML or
make build and you can customize it and
for tools like or open service tools
like SK learn and bouquet if you've got
access to the server where they're
deploying it like on AWS you can publish
using this infrastructure to to like the
actual public repo in the build folder
is where all your generated HTML folders
HTML files will live which if you know
anything about kind of Web Services
makes it really easy to deploy your
documentation as something static
because you can just zip all the files
and move them over to a simple web
service or server templates is where
templates live yes that's pretty
straightforward and coughed up hi is
where you're gonna specify any
extensions you're using the theme and
also specify any special things you want
to import so for example to read the
docs theme you can install that as a
package and then you can import that
into your Kampai and look really legit
and use it as the extension and the kind
of the workhorse of all this is that is
this index restructure text file and
this sets up your table of contents and
specifies your directory structure and
does it an intelligent way so the order
in which you list the files will give
Sphinx idea about what should be the
previous chapter what should be the next
chapter and all those kind of automated
things that you see on read the docs and
other fancy looking files but again this
was just five commands and I already
have all this generated what's next like
what do I need to know to start writing
some files say I want to write like a
tutorial for somebody to use this new
tool I wrote I wrote an extension to the
census geocoding application and I want
to make make it so that somebody can use
this like function that I've written
so the
you have to understand at that point as
well what's the difference between
restructure text and markdown markdown
is very easy to use and everyone's very
familiar with it and it's on github it's
very well supported
so restructured text and markdown are
both popular markup languages
restructure text is the backend used by
Sphinx but markdown is used by
applications like MK Docs which were
which work along similar frameworks but
the way I've seen MK Docs used is to
build up like really verbose kind of
manuals or instructions so if you go to
the so the Center for data science and
public policy they have a Hitchhiker's
Guide to data science for social good
and it is incredibly verbose teaches you
how to scope a project and the back end
of that Hitchhiker's Guide is MK Docs
and the reason it's MK Docs because they
wanted to make it like really easy for
people to contribute and markdown is
great because it's easy to learn and
it's also great for writing for the web
which is blog post or any kind of
instruction or tutorial manuals that you
want to put out there restruck your text
on the other hand it's explicitly meant
for writing technical documentation and
it has some functionality there that
makes it easier to proceed in that
direction because it will constrain you
but also give you enough freedom to
express yourself creatively so the two
big concepts in restructure text that if
you're not familiar with it are
important is this idea of a directive
and then we'll get into the next bit
later but directive is structured like
this and the standard way that a
directive is called is you've got two
periods a space the directive name two
colons and whatever argument then in the
next line you put the options and the
values anything that you're adding there
and then the content of the directive
follows and the most important directive
in in this environment is the table of
contents tree that you'll write and this
sits in your index file and this you
know okay I'll walk you through what it
is it's based
specifying okay here's the table of
contents tree for this file I want it to
have a max depth of 2 and that specifies
that it will look in all of the
documents listed and traverse their
table of contents to a max depth of 2 so
for example here I've listed oh I want
to put the file intro structure and the
file example so if the file intro has a
title a subtitle and a heading it will
go through heading and let you kind of
and I'll show what that looks like
because I think talking through it is
maybe not as effective but one other
thing to notice here is even though
these are plain text files so there they
have the the suffix rst you don't need
to specify the suffix and the order in
which you list the files will specify
kind of the hierarchy so intro should
always be first the next chapter would
be the structure the next chapter would
be example and when it's specifying the
name for the title of that page it will
take it from the title of whatever file
you have specified but maybe you know
example maybe the file example is just a
snippet of Python code that I've put as
a Python like code sample so I want to
give it another name so you can use this
HTML type inline kind of bracket
structure to specify the name is example
number 1 so here's I think this is the
most important bit to know about
restructured text and then everything
kind of follows and then I can keep
adding things to it okay ok I want to
add this idea of a caption and that's an
option I'm putting there and then I can
put you know the title contents and so
what does this look like when I take
this and I've got all these files and
then I go and I generate this
documentation I can look like this and
so as we talked about here so when I
initialize the project I set the name as
pi data 2019 and I set the author as
harima Naveed so those were the
initialization steps but look at like
all I had to do in this was take all
those restructured text files which had
a little bit of examples
and specify them in that index at rst
and this gives you the full navigation
and here you've got like a search option
you can search your documentation and as
this grows and as the projects you work
on get bigger and bigger and as more
people contribute this helps make it
like really helpful for a new person
starting we actually are using this
framework to build our onboarding
website for new hires because there's a
lot of Industry specific language they
need to know and machine learning
techniques that we use specifically in
life insurance that are helpful so this
helps them so it's like here's how you
set up this is who you should talk to
you on your first day this is all the IT
setup you need these are all your cloud
subscriptions you need access to it's
all to talk to and then okay if you have
some time read these papers we've
published if you want an exercise you
can go through like these exercises and
whatever so even setting that up even
though we're not explicitly using it to
put up documentation it's it's our
onboarding package so once you've got
this idea of the directives down so
directives are they basically are like
big block lines of text but how do you
specify inline semantic text stuff so if
you're familiar with latex which
unfortunately I wrote a lot of late eken
when I was in grad school but you have
to specify for example I want to bold
this character I want to put in this
emphasis so roles allow you to do this
semantic inline text editing in that
sense and working in machine learning or
any of this computational stuff a lot of
times you need to write math so you can
do here's like a line I could put in in
my sample code so in my restructure text
five got what is the outcome of and then
I've specified so remember the the
format is the same every single time
there's a limited number of roles so the
roll name is between two semicolons and
then you've got content with two of
those backticks so I've got math and
then I want this to look like math and
you can read the Sphinx documentation to
find out more about what that what
within like math but generally I find
that it's latex style
documentation and then when it's
generated it looked beautiful and it's
in line and you didn't have to do too
much
so between directives and rules there's
a lot to learn in restructured text
that's different
and I find this tool really helpful
because it automatically and you can
look at and you can like change lines
and I'll throw all the errors you know
that when you try to compile your 16
documentation files and then you're like
getting all these errors you can try out
little snippets here before you insert
it and it's pretty fun exercise so now
that we've talked through like this idea
of these directives and these roles and
it's very high-level it gives you this
mental model for how you should even
think about your documentation as it
should be intended for the end user and
I think here's just an example of like a
rst file so so one of the things that's
different between or that's a little
weird in restructure Texas you specify
like section headings with punctuation
so it could be like any symbol as long
as it's consistent for the same level
header so instead of using the - under
Python sample I could have used periods
and then the next time I wanted the
similar level of heading I would just
put periods so make sure you have some
consistency there because we had to
in-state it because some of our people
would write things differently but
anyways so here's an example of
restructured text file where we've
specified the title is introduction and
then the subtitle here is Python sample
so remember our max depth was set to 2
so when this documentation gets rendered
you'll see introduction and then Python
sample is like a clickable sub link and
then you've got again the same directive
structure you've got the two periods
you're specifying we want to generate a
code block it's in Python so Sphinx is
the de-facto tool for Python but they've
been adding extensions I think they've
always had support for C and those are
called domains which are directives and
roles that can be put together for a
specific language but I think it's the
de-facto tool for
on and then I want to give it the
caption this stop hi and then I want to
name it this top pie which I can then
use for inline references later and
could link there and I want to emphasize
line three and so here's my function I
do whatever is this thing on
what does that look like alright great
so we've got the introduction the Python
sample here we've got this Python
specific highlighting and then we get
the emphasize on line three which is
this thing on
so you know if you're going through you
can think about you wrote a really
complicated looking class and you want
to make sure it's like well documented
for the next person coming along you can
use this emphasis to kind of point
people to where things are important and
whatnot but remember we had this caption
here's your caption this step pie and
you can use this to reference for
example if you pull a function out of a
long module you can be like okay well
this is being pulled from this module so
people can refer back and forth and so
this very beautiful very easy to
generate how does that how did I get
until how did I get the screenshot
basically I updated all those files and
then I have to literally type in three
more commands which is make HTML because
that's what I want then I go to the
Python 3 run the server and then I go
then I need to just go to this URL
because it'll be running locally so we
can see what that looks like and if it
will break that's the exact lines you
type that perfect so and then we'll do
so start running
and then we can copy and paste this ah
great look here's the beautiful
documentation we were talking about so
I've got you know here's the
introduction piece and then we have the
Python sample
so we've sample instructions Python
sample the thing you saw earlier and
here's like we can search here so we can
see I don't know is there the word
outcome anywhere in the documentation
and look you get this beautiful thing
you're like oh I can go to this file and
look it up here so it's very lightweight
I ran a total of like eight commands and
wrote maybe ten lines to get this
beautiful templating documentation
instead of trying to figure something
else out so looks pretty cool so I'm
gonna stop the server because I want to
show something else I should have run to
mocks first it's okay alright so here
here we've you know gone full circle we
downloaded Sphinx we learned about
directives and roles we specified
documentation for a few files and then
we got you know that population together
and it's generated so I don't have time
to go into it but one of the things you
can also do is if you write really good
doc strings which you know everyone here
does right we're all very good software
engineers we write good doc strings data
scientists don't write good doc strings
they often write no doc streaks at all
they just write notebooks so when you
have these doc strings Sphinx also has
these modules that lets you auto
generate documentation from there so
you've seen it probably on the SK learn
documentation where it will show you it
will if it's in a specific format you
can follow the the Google standard and
it generates it gives you the same kind
of dropdowns for your modules and lets
you click in and look at the function
which is a really helpful way to set up
your documentation if a developer is
gonna be using it to you know write
their own code or develop off of it I've
kind of been keeping this okay what
would somebody need if they were writing
a tutorial or something along those
lines
one of the things that you know I really
promised in the session was if you've
ever wondered how those really sexy you
know read the docs or generate how do we
get there well that's very easy the only
thing we have to do here is we go to our
Kampai and remember this is our main
main master and so this generates you
know project the copyright and then
we've already got a few extensions
installed and downloaded so you install
instead extensions using pip again so
the section I want to use is the Sphinx
theme and then I've got a notebook
extension installed and I'll tell you
how we use that and then all I will do
is scroll down and update the the theme
from alabaster to this theme we'll do
make clean clean up all the old
documentation make HTML oh this may be
bad alright that's why they don't do the
live demos I see
perfect so now we've built this
documentation file and we'll view it the
same way we saw the other one you can
just navigate also ah great does this
read the docs or what so you can go
through and also look at it there's
nothing in structure sounds about right
nothing here
but you know you can go through that I
don't know why that didn't generate but
that's okay
if you ignore that but everything else
looks great and again similar you've got
the search functionality you had earlier
and you can go through and look at
specifically your indices and specify
more things there and the one thing
that's really nice about this template
is they'll give you this idea of like
next why they're not generating so
nicely they usually look a lot better
yes but so you can this this idea that
we talked about about this hierarchy
which is like next in previous which is
really nice for putting together your
packages okay okay so I'll stop this one
last time
so I wanna show it one more thing okay
so that's how you get the very cool read
the docs theme I think that's basically
all I promised but no there's more the
next bit is okay I've got this great
documentation and looks so great how do
I get it deployed so read the docs has a
specific infrastructure we're like you
can integrate your github repos and with
read the docs and then they'll publish
it and they put the back end as always
Fink's and that's the same but python
hosted what you can do is you can zip
all the HTML files you want to upload
and just upload them to this Python
hosted org and they'll display your
documentation and give you a URL that
you can direct people to for your
packages so we use Azure because
Financial Services and one of the ways
that we built this documentation because
some of our datasets are very
incident for example we have mortality
data on 25 million lives in the United
States for the past I don't know 15 20
years and so if we're publishing some
EDA or showing some new analyses on this
all of our documentation is restricted
it's on a V net server and we use the
authentication with in Azure to a
restrict access so our documentation or
any our modeling packages are restricted
on a service so what we do is we use the
azure app service and I'm not sure if
anybody uses Azure DevOps but it's
basically Microsoft's answer to github
or maybe the bot github so I don't know
if that's the same thing but it lets you
set up the CI CD pipelines and you can
generate the same documentation and
serve it in very simple four steps one
is you set up your package the second
bit is you run make HTML then you copy
the HTML from the build folder to this
artifact directory in the app service
and then you can publish the
documentation as an artifact in the
container and now because this is
running on a container you can give it
some fancy URL so you know we can call
it mortality dot mean and Creed comm we
can't do that but you know some people
have dread but for us we also find this
release for publishing client specific
documentation so we'll deploy client
models that insurance company dot Munich
recom slash smoker model slash and then
at the next bit we can give slash
documentation and that helps the
developers on their end get access and
keep updating their plugins and
integrations with the models that we
have deployed and so this is we find the
azure app service does a pretty good job
of this but again our back-end and all
this is always a restructured text and
this Fink's and so i most data
scientists all you do is write notebooks
you know somebody asked me write a
script to get scared so one of our
workarounds for this is well not
workarounds it's it's a really cool
thing you can do is this idea of this NB
stinks extension and I'll give you an
example of how you can update your one
how you can update your index so okay
let's see here okay I've got this iris
example ipython notebook in my dear
jury so I'll go to my index and I will
just add in Iris example so remember you
don't need to specify the the file
extensions for this to work and so we'll
run this again make HTML and we'll see
if this works it's nine so that's like
the ipython check the check points which
is fine oh right this won't work in this
theme so we'll just update the theme or
we'll go back to the old theme for some
reason and I always forget wim shortcuts
in front of a crowd so don't judge me
for scrolling okay so we'll do the same
thing we'll run make HTML cool so now
let's see what this looks like again
again just scroll through ah here we've
got now like a notebook generated and
this is just some SK learn documentation
example that I copied and pasted but it
can generate now your figures so if you
want to save your notebooks with outputs
too so it's like oh well I did this
analysis and I found that it does this
and I find this really helpful for
writing tutorials because you know the
more verbose something is or the more
pictures there are the more people will
follow so there's that and I just want
to emphasize how easy sphinx makes it
right so I just moved this notebook into
the same directory so I could reference
it and then I all I had to do was
specify the name of the file add in one
extension and it generated that so if
you didn't want if your documentation
you want it to be all Jupiter notebooks
for this new package or this new
modeling pipeline you've built you could
do that too so how does Fink's tie it
all together like what's going on in the
backend and is it right to say that
Sphinx is giving you this beautiful
documentation so well the back end of
Sphinx is doc utils which is another
it's an open source and it processes
plain text file
into HTML and I think one of really good
I actually saw a Sphinx talk at PyCon
and they give a really good example
saying if doc utils is like the machine
then Sphinx is the factory for your
documentation and so this the markup is
actually parsed by doc yuto's and into a
tree of node so it breaks down your
document into the high level kind of
structure so the title the sections and
the body elements and the things I
talked about directives and these roles
they're actually extensions of doc utils
frameworks but they work really well and
Sphinx has defined custom one so you can
write code for your Python projects and
so a good way to think about it it's
Fink's uses doc utils and doc utils uses
the restructure text and I think that's
a good thing to know because if you want
to start writing your own custom themes
for Sphinx you actually have to go back
and learn a lot more about doc utils so
you can build your own custom themes in
that too so now we've come to the final
piece which is what are the best
practices for setting up documentation
what I've learned in working with many
different types of people working with
non-technical working with people with
skill levels all the way from intern all
the way to you know lead engineers is
the mental model for documentation is
there's about three types and especially
in like a private entity where maybe
you're not open sourcing all your
projects
there's the tutorial there's the guide
and then there's the reference and each
of these serve a different audience
so the tutorial is very much for
somebody who's never used your package
and it should have very illustrative
example a hand wavy thing about what
it's supposed to do what you intended
and maybe list the limitations the guide
on the other hand is for maybe a
developer who's getting more familiar
with a new tool and then a reference is
a developer who's reading code and this
is where some of the auto generation
from docstrings this Fink's provides
comes in really useful so you can write
a tutorial which is probably what I
think a lot of people end up using
Sphinx for especially in smaller data
science functions like like so on our
team and guide and reference like for
example the cycler
documentation is a beautiful example of
documentation as reference and also Stu
toriel's and also something of a guide
where they talk about their design
philosophy and things like that so the
last piece is what I've heard told to me
by my manager when I don't write my
documentation is right early right often
describe your inputs describe your
outputs talk about code objectives your
design philosophy and give very
illustrating examples for the tutorials
that you want to write and make sure
your tutorials work like sometimes
you'll push changes but not update the
documentation and somebody will come
barging in like god this doesn't work
the way you said because all the
dependencies disappeared so another you
know great extension or tool you can use
as doc tests which will run all your
little Python snippets and make sure the
output is what you expect it to be
things like that and I think that's all
I have I don't think we have too much
time for questions you can come talk to
me after but I'll put this presentation
up somewhere so you can access it and
play around with free structured text
[Applause]